quieta hay gente buena bienvenidos este
es el programa llamado el impostor en
donde tus prejuicios dejarán de ser los
misma enviarán asegúrate de quedarte
hasta el final porque queremos regalar
más camisetas y se las daremos a los
mejores comentarios quédense hasta el
final las reglas al final disfruten el
episodio tienen nombre sus genitales de
ti como como llamas al tuyo
harris
jubilee presenta reunimos a siete
personas no vírgenes no soy virgen no
soy virgen
yo no soy virgen no soy virgen no soy
virgen no soy virgen no soy virgen uno
de ellos miente si el grupo descubre
quién está mintiendo se repartirán el
premio
si el mentiroso se queda él o ella se
ganarán todo el premio
el impostor
ronda rápida muy bien chicos empecemos a
hacernos preguntas y todo tiene un
nombre para sus genitales
y lo primero que pensé fue con él
parecía muy seguro muy conversador vamos
hagamos un círculo
como llamas bien harris muy bien cuando
perdieron su virginidad es un muy buen
no tenemos tiempo para la historia sentí
como si todos queríamos tener el control
de la situación y no llegábamos a
ninguna parte cuando fue la última vez
que tuvieron sexo hace 2 días
han pasado tres semanas no está
funcionando estamos haciendo cuéntanos
sobre ti esperen nos reveló
recientemente mente mente sólo teníamos
tiempo de presentarnos votar y sacar a
alguien del grupo
no sentí que ella nos estuviera diciendo
la verdad tal vez estaba nerviosa
buena suerte chicos espero que tomarán
la decisión correcta
no confío en ti me sorprendió la verdad
pensé que sería jonathan o emily no
pienso que a primera vista luzca como
una virgen si todos piensan que ya
atraparon al impostor pueden terminar el
juego ahora levanten la mano si tienen
dudas y quieren continuar el juego según
the room cuando perdiste la virginidad y
cuéntanos cómo fue en secundaria ambos
vírgenes no sabíamos que hacíamos cuál
era la primera letra de su nombre j
eso fue rápido bien soy un poco lenta
así que perdí la mía los 21 trabajaba en
un cine y él era mi compañero así que un
escándalo y sobre ti cuéntanos algo
interesante en su nombre era harmony y
cómo se conocieron myspace myspace tu
sillón tenía 14 y dure sólo 2 minutos
yo tenía 16 la chica se llamaba stage y
en la parte trasera de mi volvo también
fui un poco lento creo que estaba en la
universidad como la perdiste donde
estabas en mi apartamento en el
dormitorio no fue ayudando no fue a la
hora del camping no en un dormitorio con
cuántas personas has dormido oh dios las
víctimas de la lista menos de 10 es algo
que debería alguien virgen una lista de
chicas
en cuanto lista sé que son 3 porque no
son tantos entre unos 30 o
70 aproximadamente puede ser una 100 al
vacío cerca de 100 tengo 25 años ya
estoy viejo
no creo que hayas estado con 100
algo allí pero también más de 100
nombrando sus genitales como estaba
jugando de manera tan intensa pensé que
realmente quería ganar hasta el punto de
haberse hecho eso una relación por
cuánto han estado junto unos meses y
meses cuánto tiempo son unos meses seis
meses no menos si está afuera está por
fuera creen que soy yo solo me gustaba
la idea de sacar al tipo con la camiseta
de poni es tan obvio sabes es como en
serio es odio tenemos que hacerlo pienso
lo mismo siendo
pero me siento halagado no quería estar
a la defensiva diciendo no soy virgen
porque no tengo problemas y en realidad
lo eres cuál es el lugar más loco en el
que han tenido sexo yo podría decir que
en un elevador o en una carrera de
obstáculos en mi campus universitario en
uno de esos círculos pasaste de cero si
sólo subía y bajaba a la cama o la cama
esa es genial nunca hemos hecho muy
rubia no quizás algún día chicos
eso podría ser otra pista falsa
es como si pensaran lo mismo yo solo
quiero estar a salvo no importa cómo
[Música]
en serio buena suerte chicos tenía otra
camiseta pero me dijeron que esta
funcionaría
siento que pudo haber contribuido en
algo pero tal vez no debes juzgar a las
personas por la camiseta que usan
tercera ronda que es lo que más les
atrae del sexo qué es lo que más les
gusta hacer
me gusta el fin previa y luego al final
del día buena respuesta has dicho el
previo si los suelos ha tenido una buena
respuesta yo digo que la intimidad del
intermedio
es este un amigo para ti no es un
destino respeto por la intimidad si con
alguien a quien amas es en tiempo libre
y así con quién tiene sexo y cuánto
tiempo llevas con tu actual novio a seis
meses o cuánto tiempo estuviste soltera
no tuve otro novio en el cine pero nos
separamos y entonces tuve una aventura
si en verdad es algo creíble sí creo que
desde que nos contó lo que pero
estadísticamente si la eliminamos
ganaremos más dinero sólo usaba algo de
estrategia en ese momento creo que yo he
sido la más honesta que todos hemos sido
un cómodo como prefiero estar en una
relación que simplemente tener sexo con
alguien bien por ti pero no cambiaré mi
marido no está bien
en el fondo los estaba juzgando por su
forma de vestirse y de actuar
[Música]
de cierta manera y sé que echaran a los
introvertidos porque pensé que era una
buena estrategia pero puede que haya
sido un desastre
el intruso sigue allí estás causando
descontento en el grupo bien son un
equipo no quiero hacerte más pero por
enseñarme más preguntas jolie quiso ser
astuta pero estuvo muy lejos de lograrlo
pienso lo mismo soy jefe de distrito
espera dijiste en las últimas dos
semanas pero escuché fui a pan spring
hace dos semanas t111 es hace dos días
tuve sexo con alguien john y yo hicimos
un equipo nos miramos el uno al otro y
fue si sabíamos que estaríamos hasta el
pienso que él podría ser el impostor muy
bien pregúntame eras religioso antes de
tener relaciones sexuales y si llama tu
mamá y le digo que has tenido relaciones
sexuales un par de veces probablemente
piensa que lo he hecho aunque nunca le
dije lo hice yo sé que tenía 19 cuando
ver 16 16 y en mi volvo y de qué color
en el bulto dorado
te refieres a amarillo satinado sobre el
polvo era acolchado
no fue la mejor experiencia me lo
imagino si cuál fue la parte del cuerpo
que más te dolió después de terminar
definitivamente fueron mis rodillas está
bien sabes te preocupes está bien no fue
el mejor momento amigo soy un tipo gran
eso está bien eso es correcto primera
vez que en una cama en la casa de los
chicos y sus padres no estabas de 30 70
18 sí
pero eso es demasiado para una chica de
18 no estoy aquí para juzgarla ni nada
de eso pero ella podría estar aquí
intentando decirnos soy la mejor ella
habla de un gran número y como es tan
joven no creo porque si ella fuera el
intruso diría algo como tal vez como 10
creo que está a salvo y es historia del
volvo y sobre tus rodillas tiene sentido
esto tiene sentido para ti casi no
tenemos troy un símbolo sexual claro
eres muy bueno en eso tenemos algo
concreto 25 y la tuya 27 18 x 30 no lo
sé no me gustan los números necesitaba
que uno de ellos se equilibrará así que
estaba pensando que el intruso era
trébol pero ahora iremos con emanuel
pero él no estaba cediendo creo que
teniendo una barba pendientes y tatuajes
sea virgen no creo no me tiro los lobos
y es como sabes que eres genial no me
dejaste ahí tirado en manuel y yo
empezamos a hacer equipo indirecta y
telepáticamente crees que yo tenía un
chupetón en el cuello y probablemente se
lo hizo con una botella
es una boquilla de que no está
no es un chupetón verdadero como todos
saben eso es algo difícil de recrear así
que pensé que era algo real pero también
pensé que era enseñado sé que no eres tú
ni siquiera voy a cuestionarte y si esos
números amigos los cielos y tierra no
soy yo sé con certeza lo sé a mí sí
sinceramente es sabía que yo me cubría
las espaldas pasara lo que pasara
habrían sido dos contratos
hemos tenido un empate en caso de empate
hacemos una nueva votación las dos
personas que han empatado son jolie y
trevor
hermano tienes que congreso inteligente
usas gafas
puedo decir te va a ser lo mismo era
obvio que john y yo le iban a sacar a
trevor y luego intentarían sacarme
tuvimos otro empate podemos decir que
hemos terminado
creo que el impostor está fuera pero
solo quería más dinero levanten la mano
si quieren terminar terminemos con esto
los quiero a todos si la luz se torna
verde ustedes sacaron al intruso si la
luz se torna roja el intruso sigue en el
juego y ustedes pierden
será el eres tú
con que eras tú chico listo
dios la mayoría de las personas no
esperan que sea virgen y a menos que me
pregunten no digo nada ya lo entendí es
el juego es la supervivencia del más
apto así que lo entiendo creo que es un
sociópata oigan no juzguen a un libro
por su cubierta nunca se sabe
sigo siendo virgen porque estoy
esperando el matrimonio crecí en una
iglesia el sexo es un convenio entre
dios mi futura esposa y yo me hice esa
promesa a mí mismo a mi familia y adiós
que esperar y hasta el matrimonio
eso es mucho dinero
jubilee